okay this isn't the stir-fry video you
should finish the lentil video first
Nina's preparation for a new cooking
video I needed to show you the crazy
salad that she means the dinner look at
that looks good huh
- can it be some lentils how we eat it
every day for breakfast or lunch with
the eternal team Monday to Friday will
have it for breakfast in the morning so
why do we eat lentils because 100 grams
of lentils equals 33 percent of your
daily fiber and 80 percent of protein 18
percent iron and 10 percent of vitamin
b6 and other nutrition what would you
need would be one whole card a 1 medium
size onion and 6 celery sticks
2 orange carrot and 6 large mushrooms 3
Tomatoes and then four cups of lentils
lastly you will need 1 jar of tomato
sauce this is homemade tomato sauce that
means parents make them and you will
need 1 tablespoon of salt 1 and 1/2 of
Oregano's spice and then one tablespoon
of Basil's ok let's start first we get a
big pot and as a oil to the pot the pot
of moose hot we're gonna add the
the guardian
I'm gonna add some water to to the pot
before we got the lentils I can add the
leftovers so far it was 6 cups of water
for lentils you don't have to soak it
overnight because it's easy you only
have to cook it for around 20 to 2020
minutes to half an hour's something to
let it cook for about 15 minutes 10 to
15 minutes and I'll come back to the
delenn toast and might add more water if
I have to you don't want to add too much
because you have to put the tomato sauce
in to here okay so I'm gonna cover it
let it cook it's 15 minutes the best I'm
gonna put it down
a sauce
it's a trick to opening jars of tomato
socks because my parents like to make
these and then they vacuum them up nice
job all around inside he's giving the
instructional video here and it flips up
just like that friends
you're that woman cup of water Basil's
oregano what's happening in that other
part Nina I'll make you stir it right
okay so give them let them let the sound
simmer for another 15 minutes and I'm
gonna turn it off I'm gonna add some
water
we like it a little bit more liquidy
most people caught it lentil soup but
you can also need an asset breakfast
sometimes when we Mentos we will put
some spinach in it to mix with it in the
morning
well oh you have to finish that one is a
little salad and then I had dinner
together
I usually make three weeks worth of meso
and that frites it and then every time
when I need that just take one one
popper go out and then you eat it for a
week for the week so David Lloyd Joe's a
7 was in his lento so this is the recipe
try it now it should be easy to make
thank you for watching if you liked the
video please give another
and if you have anything that you want
me to make I'll make it for you next
time thank you I so remember the shimmer
for another 15 minutes okay thank you
for watching if you like this video
please give it thumb thumb thumb up